قرار صاد لكنه متوقع قد تكونوا اقرب الجمل
التي تصف قرار حركه طالبان بمنع دراسه
الفتيات في الجامعه هذا القرار حرك الكثير
من المياه الراكده حول الصراع الازلي بين
المعتدلين والمتشددين في ظل ردود فعل
دوليه واسعه تستنكر القرار وقد تحدد
مستقبل العلاقات الدوليه مع حكومه طالبان
بقلق تداعيات قرار حضر حركه طالبان
التعليم الجامعي للنساء في افغانستان الى
اجل غير مسمى وبالرغم من ردود الفعل
الدوليه المتواليه التي استنكرت هذه
الخطوه معتبره اياها تضييقا على حريه
النساء ومنعا لحقهن الاساسي في التعليم
وازدياد الضغوط المطالبه بالتراجع عنه الا
ان هناك ايادي تصفق مؤيده لهذا القمع وتطل
بين 2000 والاخرى لتشعر فتيل التشدد وتؤجج
الصراع الازليه بين المعتدلين والمتشددين
قرروا طالبان بحظر تعليم النساء لم يحظى
بتاييد اي مؤسسه دينيه او جهه دوليه كونها
اعتبر انتهاكا صريحا للقيم الانسانيه
والدوليه
هيئه كبار العلماء السعوديه دعا الطالبان
الى التراجع عن قرارها بمنع الطالبات من
التعليم الجامعي لافته الى اهميه الاستماع
الى ما يقضي به الدين الاسلامي من تمكين
المراه من التعلم اما الازهر فقد عبر عن
كون القرار يشكل صدمه لانتهاكه مبادئ
الاسلام وتناقضه مع الشريعه الاسلاميه
التي تدعو لطلب العلم للنساء والرجال على
حد سواء الامين العام لرابطه العالم
الاسلامي ورئيس هيئه العلماء المسلمين
الدكتور محمد العيسى اكد بان هذا القرار
ام مخالف لاجماع علماء الامه الاسلاميه
بمختلف مذاهبهم وطوائفهم داعيا طالبان الى
التراجع عنه وماربا عن تضامنه التام مع
الفتيات والنساء الافغانيات في هذه القضيه
المرتبطه بشكل مباشر بمستقبل المراه في
افغانستان
رنده الشيخ العربيه
يتعلق بقرار طالبان منع الفتيات من
الدراسه وكذلك ايضا منحتها النساء من
العمل في الجهات غير الحكوميه والغاثيه في
افغانستان من تبين تنضم الينا الكاتب
نصيحه فيفا التشجيران سيد فهد مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
بدايه
من الدراسه وكذلك من العمل في المنظمات
الحكوميه وغيرها برايك والتاييد طبعا جمله
التايد في تغريدات قبل قليل هل عاده تذكر
طالبان هذه الايدلوجيه العوده للمربع
الاول في ما يخص اختطاف الاعتدال الوسطيه
حقوق النساء وحقوق الانسان كذلك
بطبيعه الحال ال انا انا عندي نظريه مؤمن
فيها منذ زمن بعيد عن حركاتها الاسلام
السياسي والحركات المسلحه لن تنتهي بوقت
قريب وانما لديها امتدادها ولديها نفوذها
ولديها عملها ولديها ايضا ان اديولوجيه
التي تعمل تحت الارض وليس شرطا ان تكون
فوق الارض سواء فوق في السعوديه او غير
السعوديه او في لبنان او في العراق او في
الخليج وفي الشرق الاوسط وفي مصر او في
طالبان يعني كلها نظريات مستمره وممتده
وانما قد تعمل فوق الارض وقد تعمل تحت
الارض وانما طالبان لديها بعد بعد
الانسحاب الامريكي من من
افغانستان اصبح هناك لديها نفود شرس وقوي
وشديد واصبح هناك استهداف للمراه واستهداف
لحقوق المراه ولحقوق النساء بشكل بشع وشرس
الذي
نؤمن بها جميعا ان حركه الطالبان هي حركه
ارهابيه جماعه ارهابيه يجب ان توصلنا في
جميع الدول في جميع دول العالم على انها
جماعه ارهابيه وجماعه مسلحه
وتختطف حقوق النساء وتختطف حقوق البشه
تيار من التيارات السلفيه
طبعا هذا الدعاء همم حتى تبيض صفحتها وحتى
تدعي وحتى تضع لديها شرعيه وحتى تصنع
مشروعيتها
في العالم العربي وفي العالم الاسلامي على
انها جماعه سلفيه هي ليس جماعه سلفيه هي
جماعه بعد همم هي الدين هي الدين هي تكوين
من مزيج من القاعد من منظومه القاعده
ومنظومه سيد قطب ومنظومه الاخوان المسلمين
فهي خليط من هذا وذاك وان ما تحاول ان
تدعي انها من الجماعات السلفيه التي
تدافع عن الاسلام وتدافع عن العقيده طبعا
بطبيعه الحال هي ليست عقيداتها سلفيه هي
عقيده عقيداتها ما تريديه تنتمي الى تيار
عقائد
لا علاقه لها بالسلفيه لان السلفيه لم
ليست بهذا الشكل لا تمارس اداره اداره
شؤون الدول بهذه الطريقه وان هي حاولت
وتحاول وتستمر بالمحاوله ان تنضم الى
التيار السلفي همم وانما هي وانما حركت
طالبان هي جماعه هي جين مزيج من هذا وذاك
طيب قاعده هو الاخوان والى اخره ومن
نظريات سيد قطب والاعلى المودودي والى
اخره من هؤلاء القاده الذين رسموا خطوط
حركه همم او رسم الطالبان خطها على همم
اثارهم طيب انما انا اتكلم حينما اتحدث عن
عن عن تعليم مثلا حرب طالبان على تعليم
المراه او على ان المراه تدخل القهوه الى
او تمشي بالشارع او ما الى هنالك هذه لها
علاقه لها بالافكار همم السلفيه ممتاز في
الوقت ده تقول طالبا بانها ملتزمه بحقوق
المراه انا اتحدث عن هذا الكلام عندما
انقلبت على همم حكومه اشرف غني قالت بانها
ملتزمه بحقوق المراه كما نصت عليها
الشريعه الاسلاميه همم اليوم بعد عام كامل
من انقلابه على السلطه في افغانستان عادت
لتمنع الفتيات من الدراسه كذلك ايضا
لتمنعهن من العمل برايك اليوم كل العالم
الاسلامي كل مؤسسات الدينيه همم في العالم
الاسلامي رفضت قرارات طالبانتها ايضا حتى
ااه كذلك وقالت واعتبرت انها تناقض
الشريعه الاسلاميه في اي شريعه هذه التي
اتت بها طالبا في رايك سيد فهد
طوال الوقت وطوال التاريخ عبر التاريخ
هناك مشكله بين بعض التيارات الاسلاميه
والحركات الاسلاميه
ومعظم كل الحركات الاسلاميه وانما لا
اتحدث عن السلفيه السلفيه لديها موقف
مختلف من تعليم البنات حنا نتحدث مثلا عن
مسيره التعليم البنات في الخليج موضوع
مختلف لكن في في حركه طالبان منذ ان همم
اقبضت على مقاليد الحكم منذ ان تولت
مقاليد الحكم في افغانستان وهي تحاول ان
تجعل المراه درجه ادنى هذه مشكله هذه
مشكله لانها لا تؤسس لمستوى دوله مفهوم
الدوله يقوم على المساواه يقوم على
المساواه بين الرجل والمراه هي همم يعني
من ضمن الاخبار اللي قراتها قراتها منعت
همم
الفتيات من دخول المقاهي يعني المراه لا
تستطيع ان تدخل الكوفي شوب مثلا همم
تتناول القهوه همم ممكن تراجع درسها ممكن
همم تكتب مقاله ممكن يعني هذا حق من
حقوقها الطبيعيه لم تستطع حركه طالبان ان
توفي بمواعدت به يعني حركه طالبان انا
اعتبرها يعني هي نسخه همم نسخه مدونه من
تنظيم القاعده يعني تنظيم القاعده لم يمسك
بدوله همم تلك الايام كان اسامه بن لادن
ماذا يقول كان يقول ان بين كلينتون هو اخر
رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى
انه يقول انا انا رجل بلا دوله هو يريد ان
يمسك بتلابيب دوله لم يستطيع ان يمسك من
الذي امسك بتلابيب الدوله هي حركات طالبان
امس كانت في دوله وانما
وضعت كل افكار اسامه بن لادن وايمن
الظواهري
وضعتها في ضمن استراتيجيتها في الحكم
ولذلك الان
افغانستان تعاني من ازمه شرسه
اسمها
ازمه عدم عدم وجود مفهوم للدوله نعم هناك
مؤسسات معينه هناك جيش هناك سلطه هناك
شرطه الى اخره وانما مفهوم الدوله بمعناها
العميقه الفلسفه العميق غير موجود فيها
اكبر مثال على ذلك انها تجلد انها تجلد في
الشارع
وتعاقب وتعاقب من يذهب الى المدرسه وتعاقب
من يذهبنا الى همم الى المقهى والى اخره
اليوم نعم نعم وانما لا يجوز
السؤال اليوم تحت اي تصنيف ممكن ان تضع
مثلا من شارك في البدايه في وسم طالبان
تنتصر عندما
انقلبت على سلطه اشرف غني
استلمت زمام الامور والدوله في افغانستان
هنا كمان ايدها وقلبي انها حركه دينيه
منظمه بانها تغيرت حتى اصلا بعد هذه
القرارات لا زال هناك من يتبنى هذه
الافكار من يتمنى ايضا تصديرها هناك واحده
من موردات تقول شكرا لطالبات شكرا الحكومه
الطالبان وهي امراه والمراه مقتطفه حقوقها
اليوم في افغانستان همم
وهنا كان في برلمانات معينه وهناك يعني
المشكله ان احنا لا نقتنع بشكل كامل
المشكله فيه منظومه معين منظومه منظومه
حركيه معينه متشابهه ومترابطه لا تؤمن ان
حركه الطالبان
جماعه ارهابيه مسلحه هذا الملف ابحث فيه
من اكثر من 20 سنه واعرف حركه طالبان
المشكله الوقت لا
يكفي لان نتحدث لاكثر مما نتحدث فيه الان
هي جماعه هي منظومه مثل ما قلت لك هي
منظومه ارهابيه والذين يؤيدونها يؤيدونها
لانها مسكت بتلابيب الدوله فهم بمعنى ما
يدعون انهم يريدون دوله افغانستان
وبما فيها حركه طالبان وانما في عمقهم في
عمقهم الحقيقي يؤيدون حركه طالبان
ومنظومتها وايدي لوجيتها ايديولوجيه تركز
على هذه يناير ايديولوجيتها الفكريه نعم
وهذا خطر كبير جدا على الحكومات تنتبه
يعني مثلا تتحدث عن السعوديه وتحدث عن
الامارات وتحدث عن يعني مجموعه من الدول
امنتنا حركه طالبا حركه ارهابيه جماعه
ارهابيه مسلحه طارق
الدنيا تطارد الدنيا حركه ضد الدنيا وضد
حيويه الحياه وضد مفهوم الدوله وهذا هو
الاخطر يا استاذ نايف ضد مفهوم مفهوم
مفهوم الدوله نعم انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على المشاركه معنا من دبي الكاتب الصحفي
فهد اشكرك